I spoke to Elon a few times recently
about you about blue origin and he was
very positive about you as a person and
very supportive of all the efforts
you've been leading at Blue what's your
thoughts you worked with a lot of
leaders at Amazon at Blue what's your
thoughts about Elon as a human being and
a
leader well I don't really know Elon
very well um you know I know his public
persona but I also o know you can't know
anyone by their public Persona um it's
impossible I mean you may think you do
but I guarantee you don't so I don't
really know you know Elon way better
than I do Lex but um in in terms of his
judging by the results he must be a very
capable leader um there's no way you
could have you know Tesla and SpaceX
without being a capable leader it's
impossible yeah I just I I hope you guys
hang out sometimes shake hands and and
sort of um have a kind of friendship
that would Inspire just the entirety of
humanity because what you're doing is
like one of the big
Grand challenges ahead for Humanity well
I agree with you and I think in a lot of
these um Endeavors we're very
like-minded yeah so I think you I think
I'm not saying we're identical but I
think we're very likeminded and so I you
know I I I love that
idea